The basic pairing rules of DNA, A to T and C to G, are determined by the
chemistry of these nitrogenous bases. In the DNA world, a single strand
of DNA can have any sequence that
it wants, any order of deoxynucleotides with any
order of nitrogenous bases. But a double-stranded
DNA must have a complementary strand or pair
opposite to it that has the right matching
nitrogenous base across from it. A complementary strand
of DNA is just a DNA strand that base pairs with another. So for example, this
strand on the left has a complementary strand
across from it and the DNA strand here
has a complementary strand across from it. We
either refer to this as a complementary strand or
just a complement. What I want you to do now
is see if you can figure out which of the four
single-stranded molecules of DNA would base pair or complement with this
single stranded DNA here at the bottom of the screen. Just
imagine that you could take this sequence of letters and
place it right on top of this DNA molecule here. Go
ahead and select the answer that you think is best and
remember if you need help you can just use the base
pairing rules in the right hand corner of your screen.